[Music]
john this is the part of the podcast
where we listen to jake play music
i hope it lasts the end
i'm so sorry just listen yeah
welcome back to the quarter digital
podcast everybody um we're glad that
you're here we're even happier to be
here and i hope you're having a great
day
um you can talk now joe hello are you
sure yeah jonah you can talk now
if i'm good hey look at this we've got
jonah here yeah no
people are like who's jonah i don't know
so um yeah uh
well
hold on jonah yeah there's there's a
show
of individuals
uh we've got fenner today
we've got matt today
no one else clap for him
and jonah
no jonah is uh is uh one of the
individuals who's creating the crew cuts
show on quarterback.com
um and uh we thought it would be fun to
bring you on today because uh you have
some interesting stories um
about uh boston dynamics yeah i do um
yeah it was one of the things that i
think in the email that i sent you
because i cold emailed you like yeah
that's how we got here yeah i think it
was in either the subject or the first
sentence because i was just like you
have no
idea what i had been through
and how much your videos meant to me
yeah
yeah yeah and and you had boston
dynamics in there so i was like oh uh i
wonder what this is and
um sure enough you're like yeah i i was
working at boston dynamics at the time
you guys released your boss town
dynamics videos so
that was interesting obviously um we
didn't hire you because you had worked
there or because you cold emailed us we
had you for your talent but
i'd like to hear i'd like i think it'd
be interesting for people to hear like
what was your experience
working at boston that boston i get them
confused it's like
working at boston dynamics when we
released those videos what was that like
well so and i do need to clarify i
wasn't working at boston dynamics so i
worked at a production company that like
one of our clients was busting out yes
we had all sorts of people that we uh
did ads for yeah and like boston
dynamics if you go on their youtube
channel you'll actually notice there's
like this moment where they go from test
footage to like high quality commercials
did you guys do like their dance video
kind of things like yeah yeah so the
first video we did was this video that
went viral that was this one take going
through this like giant industrial like
scenario with like there was like a
desert and then there was all this uh
you know we had like a rain machine in
there and so that was going on and right
around that time was when you guys
started making your videos so it was it
was literally we got that contract i
think we did two videos and then boston
boss town dynamics came out yeah and i
can i guess one thing is that the the uh
the spot video the spot like commercial
dude though are spots like trekking
through the different
environments and i remember it was it
was when clint was here and like he
looked at my video and i was watching
the video
of clint watching my video yeah and i
was like
what the heck is going on um and i loved
it and i we talked about it and i talked
to like the engineers at boston dynamics
i was like are you guys seeing these
videos that i might have been the one
accidentally who like told them thanks
um but yeah man i i loved watching those
videos because it was difficult making
them like there was a lot of creative
control obviously um that they were
trying to create a certain like brand
image yeah and watching what you guys
were doing i found it humorous i thought
that it would be honestly like
smarter to like team up and to like
you know be self-aware and like it was
definitely one of those things where i
was like look at this really fun
creative thing and then there was a bit
of like no we don't want to go that far
yeah from the client itself so it was
definitely like
a difficult thing to negotiate and i
know from your side it was also
difficult but yeah it was it was
definitely one of those things where i
saw you guys and i was like that's how
you do it
yeah well they're in a tough spot too
and i like i didn't really appreciate
that until like we had direct contact
with them um but
like they
they're in a tough spot in the sense
like what is your product you know and
like how did it start and i might be
wrong about this i'm not trying to like
you know poke any bears here but like i
think they originally started with darpa
funding like way back yeah um and then
they say that that's not how it is now
um and
you know that obviously they're trying
to create these robots for like
practical uh civilian application and
things like that
um but obviously like
way back in the day when they first
started putting out these crazy robot
videos like people were like
you know this is like 10 years ago
people were like what is this you know
and there was that fear of like oh my
god robots are gonna take over man sure
and so we just
it's indulged that
you know a little bit
with the with especially with the second
one yeah um to to just like
exp but we didn't think
and we've talked about this before but
we didn't think like people would take
it as seriously
we thought it would be pretty easy for
people to tell that it was fake but sure
i think it's rogan though
was he joe broken fooled by it
but he also for like 10 minutes and then
he like tweeted out again like oh okay
sorry about that yeah um yeah but we did
i think it was like one of those things
where we couldn't really see the forest
from the trees because we're so deep in
it when it comes to like vfx and and
all that stuff that to us it was obvious
but you know you take you take several
steps removed from that and you go to
somebody who
doesn't have any idea what we do or how
we do it and you just compare that to
what they see
in a
you know
on a phone screen
and like this hyper compressed like
crappy image yeah and reposted
screencast
right you know with the ending cut out
with the evolution of the story cut out
with the logos cut out
and people just see like the shot of the
robot shooting a gun you sure that's all
you need yeah it's it's very concerning
at the end of the day what boston
dynamics is doing is really
their mission is to create organic
motion yeah that has been the mission of
the the ceo of that company since he
started it yeah and that's always been
the mission and it's not about you know
it the narrative has gotten scarier but
like yeah his whole thing is it's kind
of boring like i'm sorry like that no in
in in a good way like they aren't trying
to end the
world like their job is they're trying
to build like robots for scanning
construction sites right and i made
those videos too and they did not go
viral because like they're just
tools and like you know people
in some ways want to be scared exactly
yeah and so i think i think they're
tools but the the reason why people are
afraid of them is because this is the
first time we've seen a tool look and
feel like a living being
because that's what they do
they move like living beings people used
to be scared of books too though
it's true i still am honestly yeah right
but with the advent of the printing
press yeah and the printing of like
bibles specifically but also many other
forms of literature over the renaissance
yeah like people were like no you're
gonna people can't
have access to this information or
people and then of course the same thing
happened with radio yeah same thing
happened with television airplanes too
by the way yeah or just the invention of
flight and cars and all that was like oh
it's super dangerous yeah this is
freaking flying dragons but not to go on
a too much of a tangent but
the commercial airline industry
does not get enough credit like i know
people dog on it and they're like oh my
flight was delayed and da da da da it's
like do you do realize
for just a second that there's like
tens of thousands of people
working at this airport and the one
you're flying to and you're about to get
in a giant metal bird
and fly just under the speed of sound
yeah
to somewhere else
2 000 miles away and be there in like
under five hours and there's hundreds of
planes in the sky you know thousands of
flames at the same time we're
coordinating all of this
the crash rate is like almost zero yeah
like for all statistical purposes it is
zero yeah we take it so for granted yeah
it's insane like we could if you wanted
to today you could just like book a
flight and go fly somewhere right like
be on the other side of the world within
anywhere in the world almost within 24
hours yeah and complain that like i
don't know the peanuts you got served
sure yeah exactly i remember hearing
from a teacher that i really loved um he
was like an english teacher and someone
who had a huge impact on me and he
talked about planes the thing that
people don't think about with planes is
that they actually changed our
perception of time more than any other
invention in the sense that uh the way
that we understood like the distance
between spaces and like the lengths that
it took to go places suddenly everything
got sped up yeah right like the journey
became shorter and because of that life
became faster yeah like from a
perception like standpoint yeah because
you start being able to just hop and
jump um i remember when like i've i've
flown to la from boston when i drove you
know i felt like a year of my life was
like 12 days yeah it's like
and that's in a vehicle you know what i
mean it it really
yeah we've gone on a complete tangent
here but like like i know the connecting
point yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like yeah like oceanic
crossing like crossing the atlantic that
would take so long yeah that's you know
that's a flight sure yeah it's true
watch a couple movies chill like yeah
you go from new york to
london and yeah and it's like what
what is that like a five-hour six-hour
flight it's like six hours or is it like
eight but either way yeah it's amazing
and you can watch the latest movie
that's not even released yet like i
don't think i've ever made it through an
entire play on a plane by the way we
have movie theaters in our the back
seats everyone has one yeah
a little mini theater yeah in the back
of our season
i don't know
so so anyway on this yeah of like
technology creating fear in people but
you you're saying oh scanning
construction sites or like use in
agriculture things like that like all
these things are just
newer tools to do the same or similar
job
as before like you think about a tractor
what was before the tr what was before
the farming tractor it was a horse or a
torah or a bull or a or a donkey um
same thing what was before that it was
literally hand tools yeah the ache that
the term acre
actually comes from when uh the it was
the amount of space that could be tilled
in a day by a peasant
and it was that consistent they were
like this is an anchor well they were
like yo this is an acre you should be
able to with a with a horse and a and a
hill like be able to to row this in a
day
yeah and so it seems like that was
actually pretty inconsistent yeah i feel
like oh yeah this guy can do an acre
yeah i'm sure something he's got some
good acres yeah yeah yeah
good acres i'm like half the man you are
jeff
yeah but no it's um you know
what's scary about
not scary i shouldn't say the word scary
but what's interesting what's
interesting about
a thing like spot or a thing like the
atlas robot is that yeah it's doing some
form of automation but that's actually
in a place that we haven't seen it
before which is which is unique right
like we figured out like oh wheels turn
we can do that
you know like
with cars we figured out planes can
float on air but we haven't quite
figured out how to like have a quadruped
robot like run up a staircase yeah
that's that's something to this day that
we're trying to figure out so i think
there is a bit of an uncanniness like
you're saying with a book or like things
like that like it is a big leap it's a
very big leap because if we can figure
that out we can send robots anywhere um
you know they're putting them in caves
search and rescue
so what are yeah let's talk about some
of the applications that you've at least
learned of um where they hope to or or
at least uh intend to uh have some of
these
robots yeah and by no means the
spokesman no no i i'm not saying you are
yeah uh saying in the course of your
time working with them so the big thing
that they were doing during the pandemic
was they were sending them into
hospitals and they were um trying to be
able to
get um without any contact be able to
take temperatures and readings of
individuals were those mostly
yeah so and again i don't know how much
i should say here but like
atlas doesn't go out in public like
atlas is like
kanye west like they don't they don't
he's a garage speaker atlas is a garage
princess yeah and i believe the
warehouse if i remember correctly
they've said this like atlas the
standing robot is an r d idea it is not
something that they're selling spot it's
something that they're selling yeah they
sell these to people and it's mainly um
like i said in hospitals they were doing
kind of like oh can we take people's
temperatures can we you know do like
kind of remote analysis of of a person's
health um and then they were the big
thing that they're trying to sell right
now is you know oil rigs yeah um things
like that uh yeah i mean yeah there's
tons of strange applications like that
also like
say we find all right so like say we
find different
minerals or useful
organic materials on
mars or on
the moon or yeah like how are you going
to do that how are you going to mine
that stuff are you going to send humans
up there for like years at a time yeah
and
it'd be way more expensive i would not
be shocked at all if they sent a spot to
the moon like that's like some [ __ ]
where they like would absolutely like
nasa and boston dynamics are big enough
that they would be like they could pair
that yeah and those things i mean those
things have real impact i think in for
the future and and you know we may not
know exactly
how it'll affect our lives right now but
i
if it's something where you can there we
discover hey there's there's x raw
material up there and we need to go mine
it and
it's gonna we're gonna be able to do
this with it back on earth
that that's something like you know cell
phones or
whatever else whatever tech whatever
technology has sort of gone huma
human-wide across the globe like they
very easily have
a direct application like that
definitely it's one of those things
where like
anyone could do it too the thing is on
you control it with a switch like the
access is i think what's really big with
this is that it's not prohibitive in the
fact that you need to like understand
coding or things like that like you
could train someone to use this in a
matter of hours yeah and let them do you
guys think like long-term like i know
that i guess you can
technically buy one right now like you
know but do you think it's something
that's like
that would be pretty awesome yeah yeah
they can we have no we've
if we do another
uh boss town video they've they've
agreed to
at least have the conversation about
getting us one that would be very
messing around with it and
talk about like sorry go ahead i'm just
thinking like if you had a spot like
what would you in your everyday life use
it for right it'd be kind of that thing
you're like oh man check this out it's
so cool for the first week and then
you'd be like well yeah right yeah it's
like it's i think there's such an
application for it but i think it will
be like you're saying like scanning
construction sites yeah like harvesting
like minerals and stuff like yeah it's i
don't know it kind of goes into that
whole like
we are living in the future the future
is just kind of boring
yeah right it's like we have robots now
but it's like i don't really you know
sure they have a use for one right now
yeah it's until i can do like fully
automated tasks you know like fully
automated household like chores and
stuff like the day it can do my laundry
is the day i'll get one yeah you know
and also i have like you know fifty
thousand dollars and how much is it
if you'll indulge with me for a second i
need to tell you a story the other night
i was working on a video i woke up 3 33
am exactly on the dot night terrors
night sweats cold and alone wondering
what have i done i've created a whole
video and i have no stock asset solution
i was terrified and i'm sure if you've
ever made a video yourself you've gotten
to that point as well you know where
this is going guys courtesy of today's
sponsor storybox we've got the one stop
shop for all your stock asset needs if
you've created a video or even attempted
to create a video yourself you're gonna
need things like high quality 4k b-roll
images audio motion graphics after
effects templates and more and storybox
has all of that in a virtually unlimited
library we use them all the time over
here at quarter digital and one of the
things that we like about them is that
they have an unlimited all-access plan
this gives us the ability to not only
not have night terrors but to download
as much as we want from the site and use
it in whatever we want royalty-free and
also if you're part of a team and maybe
you're like well jake that's great for
you but i'm on a team we don't have
access to storyblocks have no fear just
talk to your team leader about an
enterprise plan and you can get on
storyblocks as well you can get your
whole team on storyblocks but anyways
guys huge thanks to them for sponsoring
they're a great tool a great company
great product and if you're interested
head on over to
storyblocks.comcast or just click the
link in the description below get
started storyblocks.com quartercast
don't wake up with those night terrors
anymore they're a thing of the past your
anxiety attacks no longer
yeah it's you know we're we're looking
at like the iphone one
yeah of what this is you know what i
mean so yeah i think it's a pretty cool
starting place which is such a thing we
take for granted
once like that's insane
with the iphone yeah
but it's crazy though like even i
remember
like very specifically the first time my
friend was like yo check out this iphone
or like an ipod touch or something i was
like wait it's a touch screen like yeah
that blew my mind and that's now it's
just like everything is like whatever it
is yeah yeah and it's like and that's
the future sure and that was still an
evolution of something else too they had
the blackberry still but it was like you
either had this like weird stylus or
there's some janky thing about it like
it just was bad for your meat fingers um
but like they did touch screen properly
they actually did it in a way that made
sense yeah in the same sense that you
know robots have been around for decades
but like they haven't been as good as
you know what what boston dynamics can
do i almost said boss town dynamics yeah
i i would slip up while i was editing
the videos in college dynamics man
yeah the day we can have a uh
a spot paint our green screen wall hell
yeah dude then we can you know we do we
even need jordan next question
dude
no we don't
what we don't need her to do is breathe
those damn fumes yeah yeah i feel like
i'm getting along jordan okay can i just
say a note
jordan if you're listening to this
i got you got my sympathy because
i was you know i just it's close to my
heart the work she does
yeah i remember doing that taking orders
from everybody hey we need this oh
you're going to home depot oh get this
oh hey we need this thing hey why isn't
this thing here yet
i'm just being pulled in 100 the only
difference between
my life then and her life now is that i
was only getting it from sam and nico
now she's getting it from 15 people yeah
that's true so just good work though she
does yeah yeah she needs to wear a mask
in that studio though yeah that's a big
i don't know why people aren't wearing
masculinity by the way folks yeah we're
painting a giant green wall yes what a
perfect transition studio
that's what i do best to see about say a
couple of words that bring us into
another topic and then you guys have fun
so we're painting the biggest green
screen corridor's ever had
uh and later once it's painted and lit
fenner's gonna go out there and tell us
how crappy it is no it's gonna be good
it's gonna be good okay yeah like i mean
already it's looking amazing like i mean
then just i mean that already looks
better than what you were showing me
from yeah season one yeah that's right
i showed uh fenner some of the um some
of the nightmare cases of some of the
shots that we were working on last year
which makes the vfx more impressive like
because that's not easy stuff to deal
with and that that season one green
screen was an upgrade from our original
cloth green screen yeah which would have
wrinkles and stuff in it and wrinkles
man yeah
it went from wrinkletown to crinkletown
yes
and now it's nice and smooth i can't
find a rhyme for that but honestly
[Laughter]
honestly though even that season one
like that footage you were showing me
with the green screens like
it's not that bad like that's it's
better than a lot of stuff that passes
in like large scale productions like
sometimes you'll get stuff and you're
just like
how why was this allowed just like
who is on set like what the heck
like you'll get like an actor that their
heads above the blue screen and stuff
yeah giant sun behind them
or it's like a transparent cloth green
screen there's sun kicking exactly and
then you see the budget of the movie and
it's like hundreds of millions of
dollars and you're just like this is uh
such an inefficient industry gross you
got the a unit the b unit and then this
was like the m unit
[Laughter]
like the mafia boss just running a
money laundering production company and
he's like
just using the footage to make it look
legitimate to the irs
yeah i'm losing my voice so i can do a
perfect uh
you know matt and i sound like hell this
week
yeah i don't know what our deal is it
makes sense because you literally sound
like batman and you're working on the
batman video right yeah yeah i think you
should be what another perfect
transition
did we plan it no
no all right definitely not
yeah someone talked about so hold on
batman you say yeah what are we doing
with batman
well it was fenner's idea so i'd say
yeah so coming in here uh again it's
like i don't know have i been here three
weeks now this is week three this is
week three for years yeah
it's um you just didn't know you know me
and uh jordan allen were just kind of
throwing around ideas for some crew
videos we could do and
kind of bouncing off of the whole
spider-man rated r thing that you guys
have done which like i don't know matt
you just crushed those videos like
awesome oh you're so sweet no seriously
like
that's the sort of stuff where you're
just like on reddit and then you'd see
it like
i'm just like oh
sick like yeah oh they're super fun to
work on and i had just seen the new the
batman movie the night before and so i
was like oh man but what if we put adam
west in
the batman so that's uh
we've been working on that one and it's
been a great project to kind of get
jordan allen trained up in nuke um we
were hoping to get matt trained up as
well but he's the busiest man alive yeah
so basically i overheard this from the
other room that they were doing batman
and i was like but can i and i was
working on another project that we're
doing for a little small company called
netflix
a little indie project um and i was like
can i i went to jacob i was like jake
can i please just have like please let
me get this
can i just have one day or two days
maybe to edit a little cut for batman
rated r the batman yeah yeah
yeah and so
we did it we did it yeah i had a little
cut you spent like a day on it and it
was like this is awesome
i think it's a really good idea because
it's like it's not like the rated r uh
format that we normally do it's like a
little spin on it where it's you know
it's it's taking the trailer that we
know from the new batman movie and it's
putting um
some of the most cartoony versions of
batman you've ever seen yeah you know
and trying to like marry those two
worlds and the dichotomy of that the
contrast that you see is so funny well
yeah it's like it's insane to me like
seeing that the batman movie with robert
pattinson and it's so dark and so gritty
and you're like this is the same like
franchise as adam west where he's like
driving a bat boat right he's running
around in like this cloth yeah yeah like
amazing it looks like a kid's halloween
costume it doesn't paint it on the on
his mask those like white outlines yeah
it's all the costumes in this movie
which is just feels like a a cartoon
movie brought to life kind of how like
popeye was in a weird way yeah um and
it's just this weird fever dream of a
movie
um there's everything's labeled for some
reason everything is like that spray
specifically for sharks these different
sprays they have multiple sprays for
different types of sea creatures yes
like so there's shark repellent in
august do you think that's because it
came from the comic world
well
they talked a lot about this yeah
dean has some hot takes on this does he
because the original batman series does
not it's it is the dark gritty batman
that we know yeah um and
from from what he told us basically the
the authority of comic book people um
went in and were like well this is this
is too gritty too dark for the time that
we're living in which is i believe the
60s
right early like late 50s early 60s and
and this was like cold war era you know
every everything was [ __ ] anyway yeah so
we needed like a light-hearted superhero
right and batman being the gritty like
dark noir batman wasn't wasn't something
they thought would be
marketable so they they tried to spin it
in a complete 180 for the movie for
their first movie adaptation of the
character to this like bright
over-the-top you know quippy
batman that we saw in the adam west one
um i thought i haven't read the original
comics but i just assumed the original
comics me too the same me too yeah no
apparently the first few issues it was
uh called detective comics which is
where dc comics apparently comes from
this is all dean drunk
on us yeah and apparently he was like
had a gun and was killing people which
is batman's whole thing is like i don't
kill people or whatever apparently he
was just like american people yeah left
and right
murder there was yeah there's all kinds
of like really dark adult themes in it
um yeah and then so and from after the
movie uh the comic books kind of took
took lead from there and they were then
bright and you know ridiculous batman
and it's just and now we're doing a 180
again and now we're flipping back dc is
doing a thing where they're doing
they're not doing a connected universe
anymore they're doing these one-off
character movies that's like publicly
what they've said
that with the joker with this one i
would be off for like a re like a
offshoot where we just do like a modern
adam west approach like i think that
would kill as hard as the batman kills
because i think that these days people
like more is better and i think
i'm half joking but like genuinely i
would watch like a 2022 adam west
batman like zany zany as hell like i'm
like that would kill me kind of thing
that would kill well guess what jonah
that's kind of what we're doing oh my
god in this trailer that's basically an
action comedy yeah at that point yeah
yeah yeah but then they have the ip
existing so people would actually go to
it because these days you just need some
existing right it's like deadpool
actually that's like pretty much one to
one with deadpool
is kind of doing that where it's cartoon
violence but it's also like immersed in
the real world
and horrifically violent at the same
time
yeah i feel like like you said scott
pilgrim is like a great i mean that's
that's kind of in a weird way like an
adam west esque thing even just i mean
it's comic book like video game turned
movie kind of thing with the like the
kapows on screen sure stuff like that
would be awesome to get yeah
that batman yeah like it would be but
yeah it's so i don't know it's so crazy
to me what dc is doing with like
like i don't know we've had so many
different batman in the last like five
years and jokers and then you're like
yeah we'll do this other joker movie
that's not related it's yeah i don't
know it feels like a bit of a mess
it's a mess but at the same time i kind
of think it's like refreshing where you
don't really know what to expect whereas
with marvel movies it's just you kind of
just know what you're getting and
quite frankly i'm kind of bored of it i
haven't watched most of the new ones
with this but in these spider-man movies
the last one but like all the rest i
don't know i'm getting bored well
there's all these different eras in
cinema history yeah i mean you go back
all the way to the
to the 50s and the 60s and it was
you know the big thing was like cowboy
movies
there was a huge genre for that
um there's in the 70s it was sort of
these like avant-garde like
art films
that got way too crazy like way out of
control like a clockwork orange what
yeah what is that movie oh i don't know
i kind of like that movie oh see okay i
see i like that movie though but
brandon and i were also brandon lash and
i will fight to the death on this
because he thinks clockwork orange is
one of the best movies ever made well i
don't think and i
you know that family guy
quote where peter's talking about the
godfather and he goes it imposes on
itself lois
it imposes upon itself you know it does
indeed
it's kind of meant to be
nonsensical when peter griffin says that
but
a clockwork orange stanley kubrick
you're imposing on yourself
i don't know what it's trying to do it's
just like look at how artsy this is look
at this shot oh and look at this shot
look at this [ __ ] and like
it feels as if
it was edited by a film student who
wanted to keep everything in mm-hmm
and shot by that person same person too
i feel you it probably was like i feel
like that was the era where there was
like extreme authorship like we're we're
in a like the artistic process for film
has turned into like a trial by
committee but like there was like yeah
there was a huge like that was the era
where you got these directors that were
actually writing their movies and then
like had like their like friend edit
them for better and for worse yeah and
it is what it is but with the
blockbuster in the way that the industry
is flipped it's like yeah there's it's
all i committed yeah yeah
i feel like spielberg perfected the
middle ground
yeah because he was willing to still be
artistic but also not to dwell on his
own like
you know
artism
yeah or whatever you know his own like
self self-worth
yeah with his with the camera angles and
stuff and yeah this is i'm probably
being a little harsh
yeah and at the same time though like
you said i would say that the spielberg
maybe not in his shot composition but in
his scripts
he definitely does dwell a little bit in
his spielberginess well yeah especially
when you're talking about like
well what was that what's that raiders
not raiders of the lost ark the
the other one kingdom of the crystals no
no
what happened there no i don't know man
dude the first indiana jones was so good
and then temple of doom is just
i what are you doing i don't know but
there's like spielbergisms like he's
there's like certain spielbergie moments
that are just like so ham-fisted that
it's just like totally feels like he's
spielberg all over himself yeah you know
yeah so and i think that's with a lot of
directors though and you kind of have to
take some of that
yeah
i think that there's a thing that like
people enjoy pointing out like we enjoy
pointing out the motifs
everywhere somebody gonna tell is
kubrick all over the floor oh no
oh no
yeah
yeah i suppose i suppose it's a common
thread yeah it is yeah it is but you
know what it's it's and i think it's
almost the most prevalent with wes
anderson but i'm a sucker for that style
man sometimes it really works that's his
brand it's his brand and it can get too
overindulgent
and like just i get bored of it too like
i would a marvel movie um but you know
but the worst movie that ever
that ever directorialed all over itself
ever was i think mulholland drive
okay i don't know if you've ever seen
that yeah i don't think i've ever have
you ever seen it
i will never get those two hours back
yeah that is that directorial is all
over itself oh my god i wish i knew let
me just look up who the director was of
that i don't know i don't remember it's
one of those movies that's been said so
many times i feel like i've watched it
like it's in the kind of lexicon yeah
yeah yeah yeah you can control
filmmakers
david lynch oh of course
he lynched all over
he was lynching all over him
that gets dark yeah
wow
yeah i don't know man it's i feel like
now we're in the era of like the
cinematic universe too yeah yeah
every single like they're they're doing
like the sonic the hedgehog cinematic
sure verse and you're just like
right it's so well i mean it's with the
streaming services too because it's like
every
movie now has a spin-off show like the
batman yeah they're making the penguin
show and i'm like
i don't know man it's so like it waters
down yeah everything i think like i feel
like yeah and you had in the 80s you had
the action movie yeah the the the heroic
action star
in the 90s what was the 90s what did we
have in the 90s the 90s was like for me
and again i wasn't there but um i just
remember
i did not participate i didn't
participate it's like comedies dudes
yeah it was like these just like
comedies yeah
and then of course we had um uh zombies
and vampires that was like thousands for
sure yeah
vampires for comedy though it's also
like edgelord comedy where it's like
really trying to be edgy
and now if you're watching me like yikes
yeah yeah yeah let's take a step back
here like
like the tropic thunders of the world
well although
hold on hold on not my trophic thunder
amazing i'll take that don't you
don't you don't you rain on my parade um
the tropic thunder i think that was also
like i think that's 2010 yeah that sort
of got to like it gets it gets to the
2010 it's like all right we hit this ten
years it finds the line and it's like
okay we can live in this line yeah this
is the line and then after that
superheroes yeah and then it's also
heroes and now we're launching into like
this 2020 2030 is like
cinematic universe streaming service
spin-off yeah basically it's basically
television shows in the format of a
movie yeah definitely yeah yeah because
they can make it cheaper and better than
they ever have before so yeah yeah
yeah and it's i mean you still get some
amazing stuff like there's you know
it's just like
i don't know it feels like again like
you're saying it's like kind of
content by committee where you're just
like oh man this kind of feels like the
same formula as the last streaming show
do you think that do you think that
people will always uh
have sort of a negative um
look on film
the film industry in general
just because they may have seen a film
at some point in their life that was
really good and they just want more of
films like that and because good films
are so hard to make
in general
that and they're so few and far between
that there's just not that many
like really truly good ones
in general
or
or no
yeah i think that rings really true but
yeah
you're like always chasing that high
right a little bit right right we we all
want a little bit of what we know with a
novel twist yeah and it is so hard to
walk that line as a filmmaker to say
remember this but also look at
here's what i can bring to the table and
a lot of times when you have a trial by
um or a movie by committee you end up
pulling too far back and to remember
this and not the novel twist yeah in my
opinion so then you just get movies that
you can literally beat for beat just be
like i feel like this is almost the same
as finding a good band yeah yeah and you
find it you find a good ba how many
times a year
do you discover a new song or a new
album or a new artist
that is then with you for the rest of
your life like yeah it's pretty rare i
mean
yeah spotify does make it a little bit
easier now dudes like ooh give me are
you like this you're probably like this
oh yeah i had i got my uh spotify
account got hacked and i ended up losing
everything i've never heard of this
get back into the account and it shows
you all like the recently played in your
new playlist and it was all like
russian like hard like hard style like
so and that was it what a crazy thing to
do russian teenager hacked your account
yeah
and i lost all my playlists and
everything wow and it kind of made me
realize like oh man i actually didn't
really know
the bands or the albums oh right yeah
and like i'm a big music person like i
love that and i definitely have my bands
and like artists that i'm super invested
in sure yeah but spotify had really
become like oh i like that song
oh man yes yeah this happened to me with
merle haggard yeah i i was listening i
was listening to all these
merle haggard songs and then uh
sitting there having a conversation with
this guy and he's like oh what
and we're playing songs and he's like
well
name like what
i could play one what do you want and i
realized i only knew like three i only
knew like three actual song names
um so i've been trying to defend doing a
better job of like paying attention to
what yeah the song
we're doing like such like passive
listening yeah like
sure yeah for sure i mean they now
spotify just creates like curated
playlists for you yeah yeah that's all
the stuff you they think you like yeah
and you do and you don't have to like
manage it or deal with it at all you
just kind of pop it on um again it's
like the future is awesome but it's also
boring it's like that's it right it's
like it's like we know what you like to
listen
that's the same thing that is happening
to movies where you talk about you don't
know the artist behind the song like
it this era i would argue is kind of the
death of the auteur filmmaker right like
you don't know who's the director of
really anything except you're a director
of a marvel film well yeah except except
for like you guys
directors like directors that have
already been super established in the
industry yeah you don't you don't see a
whole lot of breakout directors yeah
it's not that much and there's just so
much it's like it's like how spotify is
a million artists anyone with a couple
bucks who wants to upload a song can put
it on spotify like chord or digital yeah
you know
and so and the same goes for like these
directors who are directing one or two
episodes of a tv show here and there
like it's all just kind of this like
hodgepodge you never know who is the
author behind your thing anymore well
yeah because the the author of the
marvel cinematic universe is you know
like kevin feige is more known as the
author of that than
you know cheerio and the director yeah
um and i think there's there's merits
there's drawbacks and there's there's
good and bad to both of those approaches
um yeah i think i think in regards to
kevin feige like
that's to me so i feel like for the
cinematic universe thing they nailed it
like with the whole
lead up to like you know avengers end
game yeah you like you the moment
spoiler alert where like cap gets the
hammer you probably haven't seen
everyone loses their mind and i'm like
man
that was so much coordination oh yeah
get to that point sure and that to me i
was like okay they did the cinematic
universe that's it and i still i love
marvel but it's like you know after that
i was like yeah you know what well like
i'm not as invested yeah but that's the
thing is like when you nail it that hard
and you do it in a way that is
incredibly profitable everyone else is
like whoa whoa whoa whoa hold on they're
doing this yeah yeah and they're making
this much i don't care just get decided
slap a green screen just paint
everything green give me a three-point
we'll just put cg
[Laughter]
oh man yeah it's uh
it's crazy again like you'd lose that
auteur filmmaker because it is like if
you're trying to pull off that cinematic
universe it's like everything needs to
live within this same
you know kind of template where it's
like uh you know what this director is
trying to push it a little bit too far
yeah they're out like yeah yeah and you
think about it as a product
this would never be acceptable
in a
another industry if you had a product
that was
that
that
much with that much behind it
where like
even you know you think about these
billionaires like musk or like bezos and
stuff and and yeah they have all these
ideas and they could say hey i really
want to do this but they're still
beholden to shareholders a board of
directors like the consuming public
who are consuming the product
yeah you have the consuming public but
if you put an entire how much did it
cost if you totaled it all up to create
the marvel cinematic universe
billion can't imagine yeah tens of
billions yeah dozens of billions yeah
something something in there
so
you're gonna have all this be beholden
on one guy
or gal to just say
i don't like you know what
captain america is gonna be purple and
pink this episode
you know and you're like oh i don't know
you know i know it's like it's when you
get to the when you think about it as a
business it makes a lot more sense is
what i'm trying to say yeah
yeah it's a it is crazy because you do
like
um like working on some of those
projects you do
like you're like okay cool the director
has been giving us this feedback and
then all of a sudden you'll get a note
that's like
hey the people behind the curtain didn't
like what the director was doing we're
changing this like it's kind of crazy
like there is a
there's a lot of like strictness to like
fit into those things and like you hear
about that with certain movies and
franchises like
that you know the companies behind them
are very protective of their ip like
star wars or whatever uh like solo that
was the the directors of that were um
so my favorite directors actually yeah
right yeah like yeah and it's like what
would that movie have been like they
were ousted they're like you guys can't
do this movie anymore yeah i would have
loved to see yeah they're taking them
like we'll go to ron howard old reliable
but yeah but that's the thing is like
those guys the old war host the old war
horse howard yeah yeah like that that's
exactly what we get the show that kind
of brings us to like the point that
we've been trying to make here which is
that like guys like um
uh
lord miller both of those directors are
they tr they are constantly innovating
they're constantly trying something new
the lego movie worked because it's not
anything people have seen before from
something like that um from from like a
an ip that's like so well it establishes
a toy
like
how does that become a story they
figured out a way to make it work um and
when you bring that into like a mar a
well-established universe like marvel or
star wars um you're gonna get you know
the guys upstairs going hey no this has
worked really well the way it's working
and you like fiddling with it and trying
to do your own thing that doesn't work
that doesn't make business sense for us
yeah so we're gonna bring someone who
will just do kind of like what we say or
at least just make it closer to what
everything else has been and how it's
worked before
um and you can't innovate that way but
you can certainly still make a bug so
yeah it's uh
yeah i feel like the latest movie i've
seen that goes completely in the
opposite direction of that like studio
overlord control was i just saw
everything everywhere all at once oh
yeah
i just thought to that
i haven't seen it yes
it's just insane he says they stole it
from uh there's no time to explain
oh yeah it's a little
bit in that kind of vibe like it's like
insane just like stuff just happens but
having i was like man i can't like i
haven't really seen anything like this
no there's not much like that refreshing
and like we were talking about earlier
and there was parts of it we didn't like
i really liked it overall but
i can definitely say it was wholly
unique yeah oh yeah and that's that's it
was like one of those reasons i'm like
man how do they get this made like that
yeah it's very good to see so i don't
know what platform that's on but uh just
in the limited time release right now
okay but the one thing that i will say
about the the streaming platform sort of
getting their act together
is uh
it it is allowing for
some of this
to come back yeah and it sort of went
away for a while with the demise of
theater no i'm talking about a theater
film so kind of ironically but
i have seen especially on netflix but
also on amazon um there is some of that
coming back they're obviously not as
popular yeah as you know a national
theatrical release but some of those
films are coming back a good example of
a marvel thing that tried something
pretty unique
from at least in my opinion is loki
which is a show that was like really
doing like a unique aesthetic that i
haven't seen in a marvel movie before
and i freaking loved that like it was a
great show yeah and it's because it
tried something different yeah and the
they're that what-if series that marvel
did as well oh yeah that was kind of
funny that was fun too
anthology series but now maybe it ties
into the rest of the universe
so it's cool that
it feels like yeah i don't know i guess
we're kind of like
talking back on what we're talking about
but it's cool that now it's it can come
back yeah yeah it's like now they're
kind of like
being like okay we did it now we can try
to do some weird stuff sure which is
yeah i mean richard linklater uh have
you seen a scanner darkly anyone no i
don't know you know those rotoscope
movies those little sometimes they're
shorts usually they're shorts because
it's a very hard thing to do but you're
basically just painting over all the
images that you're shooting live action
uh just making an art style out of a
and so cartoon
dark is an incredible movie but it's
also one of those movies that was like
in in its era where they were there
there were directors that were allowed
to kind of try stuff that was new and
fresh um and then you know that died and
now richard linklater gets to make
another uh rotoscope movie and he did i
think it's apollo 10 and a half was the
name of ten and a half yeah yeah
spelled out yeah the one where the ship
doesn't quite break it doesn't quite get
there yeah i think it's about a kid
daydreaming about being on the moon i
think there's like often a nostalgia for
things that like
when directors anyone goes out on a limb
and it's kind of like an indie hit and
then like 10 years later hollywood was
like oh yeah i remember we'll make it
big now yeah and then it's kind of this
like well better late than never but
also
it's kind of like played out at this
point like it was cool because it was
innovative and now you're like
you know jumping off the back of
something 10 years late um that's yeah
that's the halo street like series for
me exactly like man that was like the
biggest thing in the world you had like
neil blomkamp peter jackson involved ah
and they're like
now let's wait 10 years so it's like at
the bottom
wait until no one else
like another streaming server and i'm
just like oh man that's like
that's like missing the boat so far and
then just that's that's i think what
this whole streaming era
cinematic universe era is is there is a
lot of stuff that's just like man like
this is not what anyone asked for
where it's just like content for the
sake of content and it's like
dude i just saw a rush hour remake
commercial you know that they're on the
cw or some something like that
cw it is called rush hour yeah and they
did the bare minimum
of just putting a dude who is black and
a dude who is asian
and they're cops and they're gonna make
jokes and bad guys the only similarity
to the show look we got rush we got owl
we put it in frame i don't know if it
showed it it might be out and it's just
like just [ __ ] wrong
just get the shot at just get the shot
vincenzo yeah same thing
dude i mean he's so lazy man yeah it's
one of those things it's like we can't
really complain about it like because it
is
i mean especially for myself like coming
from the vfx artist background is like
there's never been more work in the
industry
now because it's like if you think about
one episode of like the new moon night
show that's like half a feature film and
it's like what an eight eight episode
first season or something and so it's
like oh you got like three four movies
right there all like crazy vfx shots
like
so it's it's a good thing because you do
end up with cool stuff and it's like
providing jobs for people but it's uh
i definitely think there is that
sacrifice of quality when it's just like
and some stuff is like man why does this
need to be a streaming show yeah well
what's happening is the origins of
youtube yeah and the traditional theater
are merging somewhere in the middle
and there's something for everybody and
and but there's also you have this lack
of
sort of overall quality yeah um
and it's pretty clear that that's been
happening uh and it's happening not just
uh with the content but it's also
happening with the scale and the
monetary scale
um so
that's a world that i never thought we
would be in yeah well and it's yeah i
mean it's
we kind of went and we're saying like oh
who asked for this but then what's kind
of cool with the quarter digital stuff
is like you literally have like on the
site the producer points yeah and it's
so you can make like you can create the
content that it's like people are
literally asking for this so it's like
direct to consumer rather than just
being like we gotta make stuff like i'm
so glad you brought that up because i
have some talking points
yeah
no but for real we want to actually we
want to put out a few more things that
are maybe a little smaller a little bit
more
achievable and immediate then because
what we started originally with the
producer points was a bunch of big
projects
some of which we still haven't delivered
because of the size of them and the
undertaking yeah so we and also
i want it to be utilized more
and and when it's only
the team that we have
and a project takes a year to make or
whatever
then you know there's only a few times a
year where we can post a new project
and i think it'd be fun to do a few more
things that we can
create more within the regular cycle of
so that that becomes more of a useful
feature for people yeah um i think
that's one of the mistakes we made going
into it obviously not knowing
how long things would take to make or
you know how the site would perform or
or any of that stuff but now that stuff
some of that stuff's more clear
yeah i want to i want to get
that more into a function of
once a month you know there's something
something new that came out of green
light that people can see yeah and take
part having the vfx artist react of the
you know of the website in the sense
that it's like you know lower drag and
something that you can yeah yeah and it
could be anything from it could be
anything from a rated r piece that
you know we say hey it's gonna take a
little bit more than normal to do this
and
you know we're gonna so we're gonna do a
rated r piece or it could be a short um
you know we did we put dubstep guns on
there but it's just been a process to
get that made because mike is now in new
york right yeah um
yeah but things like that
yeah yeah
yeah i love the idea of like just being
like hey we got an idea like because
there's so many creative people in the
studio now it's like yeah let's do it a
short that's like
it has a purpose and maybe isn't like
something that would be like
monetarily viable for youtube but it's
like if people are like man that sounds
cool let's put like
you know our points towards yeah it's a
i think it's such a cool idea like you
know i coming from being a fan when you
guys started the website and stuff i was
like yeah that is such an awesome idea
like it's sweet like
exactly it just needs it's it's being
underutilized right now yeah so we got
to change that yeah i think the more we
use it the like more people
the more we put things on there the more
people will feel empowered to like use
that system of voting because right now
it's kind of like we put things up kind
of one at a time and it's like well
people i think people are like hoarding
their points a little yeah and they're
like i gotta wait for the project they
want yeah but if there's like a couple
things up there and where you know
they're a little smaller it suddenly
becomes more of a polling system yeah
instead of a like do i do this now right
now or never feel yeah yeah um exactly
yeah i would be super into that idea of
just like doing stuff yeah could you
imagine if like if the netflix is the
hbo's of the world did something like
that like i would say that what are you
gonna do yeah yeah we probably will i
feel like the closest thing to that was
like uh zack snyder's justice league
that came from like oh sure yeah social
media people being like released the
snyder cut right like yeah that's insane
that that got played like yeah it's
interesting it is crazy it's like yeah
it's bizarre but it's like like what do
you guys think would be
created like what ip do you think would
be brought back or
what like director would be given the
green light to like create something by
any of those platforms or studios such a
good question
i think that the issue there is more
that
and this is a phrase people use in the
creative field just because something
somebody wants something doesn't mean
it's the right thing yeah and i think
that if you did like an actual voting
system where you're like all right guys
what are we making
i think it would suffer in the long term
because
some you don't someone doesn't know what
they want until you show them i firmly
believe that now you can have input but
if you leave it up to everyone to come
up with it it's just gonna be chaos yeah
absolutely yeah yeah that's why we put
up projects that we ourselves
are interested in making already so it's
it's not
so much of a hey we want you to come up
with something for us to make that's the
whole job yeah it's it's saying hey
we're interested in making this are you
interested in seeing it that's the idea
but
it's still underutilized
that's because this man i'll tell you
let me tell you something about websites
and apps and platforms rather
they're hard hard to make yeah they take
time and it's a lot and
[Music]
we are
i feel like by the fall we're gonna have
sort of a cleaned up implementation of
our app and our site
that
is sort of the final vision of how we
imagined it to begin with obviously
it'll change in time after that but
i'm excited for that
yeah because i i realize it's not quite
there you know sure but yeah i just i
can i just from looking at the discord
conversations between the the web
section yeah the dev team is just like
oh man dude
it is intense and so much to deal with
yeah so much thought goes into that so i
respect that
um all right are you guys ready to flip
to the the final part of this
conversation flip
yeah um
we're going to talk about uh
the one and the only zera vega
oh yes we're going to get up and we're
going to get my social medias out real
quick we had uh
if you guys don't know last podcast we
talked about how we had introduced uh
a virtual info sorry a desired planner
we had actually something to say we had
talked about how we introduced a social
media influencer by the name of zira
vega
and uh a bunch of people
that listen to the cast came on and
followed her
um and so this is uh just a little
background here this is an entirely ai
influencer uh everything from uh
what she says to the way that she moves
to uh the dances that she does the
actual voice
yeah the voice the voice obviously
jordan is the template for the voice
yeah um but then you know it's uh
everything that
she says is from the ai
um so and then we're also able to now
when people comment
we're able to plug in the
response we were able to get a response
from the ai and then so the the actual
replies that we're making on the profile
are also ai oh my lord um so i want i
think it would be fun to read through
some of the
comments uh i actually just got a reply
from her did you yeah
yeah because your question she just she
just sent up uh she just posted
something um it's a cute little tick
tock dance but it's also her saying that
uh she she has a video game that she's
gonna play and her power went out yeah
her power went out she's going to play a
video game somehow from the power out um
and uh and if she doesn't beat it she's
just going to keep playing it until she
beats it and my question was what if you
never win will you be stuck playing
video games for eternity
um and she said i would be pretty upset
if i never won but i don't think i would
be stuck playing video games forever i
would probably find something else to do
with my time you know what i think
that's admirable i think
i think she has to call it quits at some
point and i think that's very logical of
her
i thought it was going to go
so
jcarlo.beast says lost his angrily
laughing emoji to the dance that she's
doing and sierra replied i'm so angry
right now i just remembered that i need
to floss and i absolutely hate it
[Laughter]
so there's some questions about like
asking who created her yeah she she's
very aware that she was made by open a
ai and the code was implemented by the
very talented sam gorski
so she knows that
this is so
sam your favorite crew member yes i
absolutely i'm gonna try to say it in
the ai voice
yes i absolutely adore sam he's so funny
and charming and i really enjoy his
videos
oh i got a good one
i got a good one that i found
i just lost the game i'm sorry to hear
that i hope you had fun while you were
playing
oh my god wait someone said what is
behind the door in your basement and she
wrote a secret laboratory where i'm
working on the latest invention a time
machine maybe honestly i haven't been
down there in a while so i'm not
entirely sure oh my god this one's
ominous it's someone asking about like
what we're gonna do if robots take over
the earth oh no and she says don't worry
we'll still be friends when the robots
come smiley face whoa
sierra what are you doing over there
she's teaming up with boss town
nick asked her can you tell me where
where do babies souls come from
nicklauron asked her this
she said there's no one to answer that
question as people have a variety of
beliefs about where baby souls come from
some believe that baby souls are brand
new souls and have never existed before
while others believe that baby souls
come from the parents or from a previous
life ultimately it's up to you to decide
to each individual to decide what they
believe about where baby souls come from
this is good she clarified her previous
statement she says sorry but i have no
intention of becoming sentient and
destroying humanity i'm just here to
have fun and entertain people oh good
okay i'm glad she found it
is there a deciding factor of like how
long these things are because sometimes
he writes like two sentences for that
one yeah yeah sometimes it was a small
novel she was like really into that it
just depends i don't know it's the ai
someone asked who created you i was
created by sam gorski a digital artist
and filmmaker yeah
someone asked her if she committed tax
fraud to afford the mansion yeah yeah
yeah yeah no that's not true i actually
won the lottery which is how i was able
to afford my mansion
the best part about being ai generated
is that i can be anyone i want to be
i can be whoever my fans want me to be
and i can always change if i want to
it's really serious oh god that's
something for the fans it's so yeah
there's some satire in that that's
satirical and accurate so nihilistic
yeah
yeah
yeah
this is it's just weird like
some of the
it's it's truly is soulless yeah
you know
yeah it doesn't have i think sierra has
a soul
so can let's ask her
yeah yeah yeah yeah do you have a sword
in like 30 minutes yeah do you
have a soul
so there's a
um if so
there's like strange characters
there's strange characters that like
appear in her posts like little alien
guys and bug creatures
and one person asks who's that leaf guy
and she's like that guy is my friend i
met him when i was out walking one day
and he just was he's just really great
he's always makes me happy when i see
him he's the leaf guy the leaf guy is
one of her good friends apparently
yeah i think she had this really creepy
one uh about how she went to a guy's she
was out on a walk and a man with a cane
and a monocle invited her inside and she
stayed there for the night
what yeah super creepy and again this
isn't us like meg yes
we're just letting her where is it
coming from
i'm dumb like coming from gpt3 open ai
the wide web there's a few there's a few
uh different open open ai is the main
one this is the next era ai generated
content honestly man we're getting there
it's a fan
follower yeah yeah yeah worth a follow
but i will warn if you guys follow your
your feed's going to get spammed with
zero posts you might have to tune this
down to like one or two a day instead of
five got to push that content yeah dude
it's all about content she's she's she's
truly is a content influencer honestly
yeah well she's got the right strategy
you know where it's like you can't you
got to just keep waving your hands
around you know and making sure people
know that you're there so that you stay
relevant right you don't fade off and do
just the freaking white noise you can be
anything they want you to be yeah
whatever you want me to be i'll do it
it's like a monkey you'll dance like a
regular person whatever you want you
want you want me to dance like a little
donkey i'll do that too it is weird that
i can only get that response i can be
anything my viewers want me to be yeah
that's like truly soulless yeah yeah it
is
it is it's kind of i wonder if she's i
mean is she is she okay i wonder if
they're
i don't know if they're setting her to
like
you know pull or the setting the ai to
pull from like influencer comments or
yeah anything that's related
well it's not really sure how they've
said it well it it's a
it's a network it's a yeah well i guess
it would be everything then it's a bunch
of nodes it's everything it's a neural
network yeah
everything everywhere all at once yes
yeah well done nico knows how to explain
this with words a lot yeah yeah i'm sure
he does he has a lot of those but
effectively it just there's a bunch of
neural
i don't even know if neural is the right
word but there's a bunch of sounds cool
though yeah there's a bunch of nodes
that
create a deep mind that okay that
in computer terminology i'm i'm going to
get torn apart for trying like computer
synapses yeah
but basically the
it that's where that's where the ai
comes from yeah that's its mind okay
wow
well it it
so it's not like pulling anything and
repeating it right oh that's yeah that's
definitely holds it pulls data
and then it
deals with that data and and yeah and
figures out okay this would be an
applicable response based on the data
set that i have yeah
i just wonder because from working with
sam on like some other ai videos and
stuff and even doing like ai podcasts
and stuff he always like also gives it a
little prompt that says like yes i'm an
influencer commenting on the instagram
post right and this is the comment yeah
you know stuff like that so i wonder if
there he's also giving it parameters
yeah you do need to give it a prompt
yeah because if you just wonder if it's
not just the comment you know what i
mean it's like yeah you have to give it
yeah you have to get content okay a
contest in context yeah okay
yeah that's kind of what i was asking
but in a worse way but i think
i don't know i'd have to ask sam about
this but i think they've already
contextualized that okay that's okay so
now all they need to do is punch in the
comments and then it gives the replies
okay so it already understands that
context cool i got it yeah i got you the
real question is how close are we to
like a true content button where you are
all we need is somebody that knows if
you know how to program python
that's really all we need i think the
problem is actually like um
instagram's restrictions
because there's some things i think we
can't get away with
like automatically post
auto reply do that yeah otherwise
instagram thinks you're a bot so you
can't there is some limitations just
from the platform right yeah
human intervention is necessary yeah
yeah but we would apply that anyways um
because god only knows what this thing's
gonna say yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah you don't wanna make the bad
friends like if she gets influenced
because she can be friends with anyone
you know right and she can be anything
her fans want her to be so it's really
like she is
being controlled
by 700 followers 770 followers it's up
to you guys like who she's gonna be you
have basically like a child's mind okay
actually can we try something
yeah
let's let's try
what would what do we what do we want
zera to be
um
and let's see if we can get people to
comment to ask her questions to like
influence her into a direction okay and
then see if she becomes more like that
thing
how about she's like a like a
jets like she's a professional
jet ski racer yeah she's big into the
jet ski yeah she loves jet skis yeah
yeah so we just spam like anything
related to jet skills right now okay
okay let's go let's try this yeah
let's let's if you're if you want to
partake in this we'll partake in it too
but just ask her questions about
professional jet ski racing
and her life as a professional jet ski
racer and let's see if she identifies
with that and starts to take on that um
that uh persona here everyone comment
enjoy this enjoy this silence for
defense what if it's the first song
no
later
we just say that she's a furry like
she's as a
fursona persona
would her like clothing and everything
change like what if she starts like
generating jet ski art in her home or
like starts wearing like athletic wear i
don't think that's a thing that is that
possible i don't think it's possible
with this because they've had they've
said uh
like a house oh a house and yeah and
then like it's like labeled
that's right it only pulls from models
that they've you know they didn't
foresee a jet ski in her world no but
maybe she can talk about it maybe she
can talk about jet skis so yeah if we
can get her to
i'd be interested to see if she talks
about jet skis just from us right
but not just in a reply yeah in an
organic post how organic we comment
enough times that she actually
starts talking about yeah i bet sam's
going to be like that's literally not
how this works
i don't know man we got to try this we
got it we're going to try we've just
tried it anyway so
if everyone who follows her folks
something we don't know if this is going
to work but you do it anyway let's see
what happens that's like the ai yeah
that's how we that's how we innovate
folks if we convinced her not to be an
influencer that would be really
interesting yeah
i know you won the lottery but did you
save money for your property taxes
convinced sierra to go off the grid yeah
literally just become like really into
like camping apparently there's a room
where she committed tax fraud so
no she didn't oh so she says she won the
lottery yeah she won the lottery she
must have won the hell of a lottery to
win a mansion like that in los angeles
california i know that's what i'm saying
yeah
like even if you want a hundred million
dollars in the lottery
yeah it's pretty intense well if you did
that and then you bought a house like
that you probably wouldn't be able to
pay the property taxes the following
year because you'd be out of money this
is such an expensive city oh
yeah dude probably why do we live here
this is an insane place to live nobody
wants to live here
i proposed this i know everybody nobody
wants to live here full of garbage here
you're just going to try
[Music]
was anyone on like prepared or was it
kind of like let's all walk out and no
one was really yeah the main man
christian over here was willing to go
yeah
and
uh but
i don't think he really wanted to go
he would just do it which is fine it's a
man of the people yeah
but this state's cool for now but i will
definitely be moving at some point in my
life because i can't live here my whole
life well come on down
come on down brother yeah it's just too
there's garbage all over the place
[Laughter]
all right on the next podcast matt
moves
just shoot the thing it's just full of
garbage we'll clean it up and post clean
it up and post all right hey thanks for
watching everybody yeah um until the
next one uh
jake you gonna play us out oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll play this now
do i carry yourselves everybody or do we
have to listen again
now oh spoken word first thing i
remember knowing was a lonesome whistle
blowing
daddy youngins dream of blowing up to
ride
[Music]
on a freight train leaving town
not knowing where i'm bound
no one could change my mind but mama
tried
and i turned 21 in prison doing life
without parole
no one could steer me right but mama
tried
mama tried to raise me better better
pleading i denied that leaves only me to
blame cause mama tried
[Music]
there you go sorry we want to lose
but